foreign
Vegas last week to meet and interview
the president of the USC UFC
Dana White and we're not exactly sure
what to expect we were highly impressed
it turns out that his experiences of the
past several years are very similar the
experiences of millions of business
owners in this country the difference is
he found a way to keep going he told us
that during the coveted lockdowns the
Government tried to shut him down
completely and of course the media were
intent on helping the government do that
CBS for example reported that quote Dana
White is an epidemic on his hands The
Washington Post report that quote
epidemiologist blast UFC president Dana
White
of course there was never any evidence
that Dana White had in any way
contributed to the pandemic it was all a
lie
so the point of the story however is
that Dana White kept UFC alive during
the lockdowns he did not bow to pressure
he persisted didn't lay off a single
person it's an inspiring story here's
part of it
Dana White thank you for having us
thanks Robin never done an interview
with human blood on the floor and I like
it so the first thing I noticed having
watched a lot of UFC is how small this
is
the octagons right in real life there is
no place to run yeah it's so this is a
smaller version of it that we use here
at the Apex but when we go into Arenas
we use a bigger one this would look like
a like a matchbox in some of the Arenas
that we go to the the one that they
fight in uh on pay-per-view in arenas is
much bigger what do the fighters think
of being locked into space this small
it's funny because we used to talk about
you know fights are probably more
exciting and more there's more
engagement and a smaller octagon but
it's not true we actually did studies on
it and uh there are just as many
finishes in the big one as there are in
the small one interesting
so this is your Arena where a lot of
your fights take place in your building
in a world you completely control 100 so
this
ironically was built we were literally
putting the last nails and screws in
this place right when covet hit
so it couldn't have been more perfect if
we're actually allowed to use the arena
because they shut Nevada down and uh you
know we couldn't even do it in our own
facility that we controlled and that we
could have created a bubble here but
they you know the government would let
wouldn't let us so you're in the sports
business and I should say You're really
the only figure left in American Sports
who controls the sport I mean you're in
charge of the sport right so that's not
a model that exists anywhere else but
you're responsible for the sport and now
you can't have in-person events what you
know where does that leave you the
beginning of covid yeah it was tough you
know I say it all the time covet is is
the uh was the toughest thing I've ever
had to navigate in the history of this
company and if you look at where we came
from that's actually saying something
but my attitude and my thought process
was this was America we we don't quit we
don't give up and we definitely don't
run and hide in our houses so I figured
there had to be a way
so covet happens companies start laying
off big percentages of the workforce
they don't know how long the quarantines
are going to remain in effect they're
indefinite and they've got these
payrolls they have to meet you did not
lay people off no my people a lot of my
people around here have been with me for
a long time 10 to 20 years and you know
we do events every weekend these people
work hard they've been dedicated to this
company to me
and you know if you look at covet it's
probably the scariest thing to ever
happen in the history of my life and to
all of a sudden just dump my employees
uh the minute something bad happens it's
just not the way that I'm built it
wasn't going to happen no matter what
I'd rather have seen the whole company
burn and go down in flames before I
would hurt my employees so you paid
everybody paid everybody
so that introduces a math problem though
into your life because you got a lot of
money going out and no money coming in
right what do you do
figure out how to put on events you
figure out how to
keep the show alive and keep it going at
the time you know I'm close to the royal
family in Abu Dhabi and they were doing
testing over there
well if they were doing testing we could
do testing here it was just a matter of
figuring out how to do it and figuring
out a place where we could go where we
could build a true bubble and make sure
the people were safe and and put on
events so you went to Abu Dhabi yeah so
originally we were looking for an island
Islands made sense Mike Tyson called me
and had some guys I don't remember what
island it was that said you can come to
our Island and and do the fights there
was literally no way there was no
infrastructure there no nothing so that
was out and then we ended up talking to
Abu Dhabi and they suggested Yaz Island
in Abu Dhabi and it was really the only
true bubble that existed in sports
because they brought people into the
workers the workers in the hotel the
workers in the restaurant all the people
that were yeah as Island were tested
before they went there and they were
there for weeks being tested regularly
before we even got there then the people
that we were bringing over we test
tested flew over on our own private
plane that only we were on got to the
island we were tested again and tested
multiple times up until the event
happened and then everybody would go
home so was the only true bubble that
really existed so that allowed you to
keep your sport on the air when
everything else was shut down right why
didn't everyone else do that
I don't know I don't know you know what
I took a lot of heat took a lot of
bullets took a lot of uh on what crowns
criticism well you that's what the media
does media does nothing they they they
never built anything nobody depends on
them for a paycheck but all they do is
sit back and criticize I'm going to kill
people I care more about money than I do
human life I I heard it all and and the
New York Times as you can imagine was
was blasting me daily
because you were trying to keep your
employees paid and fed and keep your
business going right because you're
you're trying to figure out solutions to
problems you're trying to you know
everybody felt like it was this
narrative during covet that if you
didn't run and hide you were Reckless
you were a monster you didn't care about
other people uh and the list goes on and
on so how did you take that they were
working good [ __ ] they're right
these guys have nothing to worry about
they were writing horror stories every
day and they were all working but how
did you keep that out of your head I
mean it's easy to say I don't care about
criticism but when you are criticized
like that in the New York Times the
biggest newspaper in the world it's hard
to keep it out of here it really wasn't
you know I I live in like my own little
world over here in our own little bubble
and I knew that if I went and I figured
out a way to do it that my team would go
with me and I knew that the fighters
would fight so as long as we were all
aligned and everybody felt the same way
and then and you know we weren't 100
aligned there were some Fighters that
were scared and a little nervous and
they didn't have to fight if they didn't
want to nobody was being forced to fight
if you wanted a fight you could because
that's how these guys feed their
families too and how you know so yeah I
kept everybody working was there any
coveted death around you I mean the New
York Times said you were killing people
did you there was no coveted death you
know there were people who caught covid
and I was sending out weekly videos to
my employees listen enjoy this time that
you have with your families relax
if you get covered or anybody you care
about gets covered make me your first
call and we'll we'll get you taken care
of we'll get you looked at if you need
toilet paper toilet paper was a big deal
at that time we'll get you toilet paper
if you need food and you can't get
groceries or you need anything
call us and we'll take care of you
through covid me and my team became
stronger than we've ever been and then
once we it was time to get back to work
I mean there's still companies today
that people aren't back to work yet my
whole team has been back to work like
pop maybe like three four weeks into the
beginning of the pandemic and we've been
working straight through this whole time
did you lose anyone we didn't lose
anyone no we didn't lose anyone so you
were loyal to your employees and you
never had staff problems 100 it was
loyal to my employ my employees were
loyal to me for the last 20 years
then when when they hit the fan I was
very loyal to my people
and they were loyal back and and and
we've gotten through this thing we threw
one hell of a Christmas party last year
and we had a blast and we partied and
had fun and uh we brought Kid Rock in
Kid Rock came and played no everybody
yeah Kid Rock came and played for
everybody and uh it's almost like it
never even happened here so you're
basically showing the rest of the
country how to
stare down adversity and Achieve and
Thrive despite it it was pretty
impressive story did any politicians
call you to say I'm really impressed by
what you're doing
um you know
the president at the time did you know
obviously he he was very into it
um
you know um
Florida was was massive for us you know
Florida I would I would equate Florida
to Abu Dhabi during these times what did
Florida do you know the the governor
governor DeSantis and the mayor of
Jacksonville Florida told us come on in
we'll host you here you can do your
events here
I have fighters from all over the world
so the fighters that were from other
countries we all brought into Abu Dhabi
all the Americans we fought down in
Jacksonville Florida so we were still
able to run our business
like nothing was even going on other
than we didn't have fans we didn't have
a live gate because of them then Tillman
Fertitta down in Houston
was saying I need you here in my arena
in Houston how quick can you get here
so it'll be there as soon as you're your
mayor lets me you know so we figured out
a date and then it then it became
Houston Texas Jacksonville Florida and
Abu Dhabi
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight